really actually that's a good segue
we'll do this cause we'll talk about the
suspicious package i guess not that
it matters all that much but it goes
into what i'm saying about this
extremism from
from the left like if a lot of these
people on the left
view the left and right as defined by
status quo versus the revolution
like from a french revolution
perspective yes who's for the status quo
so therefore they're like tim paul's
obviously right wing he likes the system
he's a reformer liberal
it's like well i mean that's correct i
am absolutely yeah i'm a liberal and
for reforming but in terms of their view
of having a revolution
yeah it does because i am not for their
revolution
they're weirdos so then what happens is
you get someone like bernie sanders
who's like
we're gonna vote we're gonna change the
system and they're like true capitalist
nationalist you're not left-wing i kid
you not they've called bernie sanders
right wing
are they calling him that there was
there was a post there was a post
on uh the world socialist website that
called bernie sanders
a nationalist capitalist right yeah
here's the thing
it's not left listen listen listen if
left and right are defined by who's in
favor of the revolution
what happens if you're on the left but
then you like demand a revolution
of the left so you're even further left
oh wow now the far left is right to you
yeah that's what they're doing well i
don't know if you know this tim but
bernie sanders is actually a moderate
you know that in europe he would be
considered right wing
yeah so dude i cannot stand that's like
yes all right yes
left and right are subjective there is
not like a set definition that we've
stuck with
from the french revolution with respect
to policy positions that have carried
over
since then but yeah the left and right
shift in your nation and it happens to
be the case that bernie sanders is
pretty far to the left in the united
states
he's he's almost as far left as you can
go on the economic scale yeah he's in
favor of
the worker controlling the means of
production yeah well this is also funny
they do this thing where they'll look at
european politics and say that if we
want to be more objective we should
define our political spectrum in
relationship to theirs
and they'll be like oh well like in
europe this is actually a moderate
policy xyz but like
nobody in europe uh has any policies or
at least most countries in europe do not
have policies
on abortion which are as left-wing as
the democratic parties
is so there's there's this graph i like
to show of
the democrats moving super far left and
the republicans staying where they are
comes from the new york times article
called what happened to our political
center of gravity
but they did this clever thing where you
see the democrats go super far left
but then they're just over a black line
that says median party
and so when leftists see this they're
like wow so the democrats are center
left
that's funny and republicans are far
right it's like no no no no
they're left of the average european
party
and europe is very far left yeah exactly
so that means we are more far left than
europe yeah the democrats or the
democratic party i was thinking about
like the way an atom
works with like the heavy center and
then the electron and the proton is much
heavier than the electron but they have
equal magnetic charge so it's kind of
like
the right is like 90 plus percent of the
population
now because this far left is so radical
and all over the place they have
relatively equal magnetic charge because
of social media like equal amounts of
influence it seems like even though
there's so many
few so much fewer people on the list i
would actually disagree i think it's the
opposite
i think that it's always been the case
that most people have had pretty like
socially conservative or
uh maybe even libertarian views but the
mainstream media has always been
left wing or center left and so once
social media came about and you actually
had people who were voicing opinions
that didn't necessarily conform to the
status quo of the dominant media culture
right-wing views started getting more
airtime and this is why they say things
like social media is biased towards the
right because while on social media you
can actually see a right-wing
perspective
right right right they're surprised to
see it yeah but i think what you're
talking about that power that the left
has
is because wall street is literally
supporting it yeah so i use wall street
as kind of a catch-all term for the tech
billionaires the media billionaires
and literally
so how was it you know bernie sanders
like you got a vote biden
but vote for the guy who's being funded
by wall street yes that's insane
it's completely insane the fact that
like and joe biden was playing so
friendly with all the people i'm sorry
not joe biden but bernie sanders would
play so
friendly with all the people who he said
were part of the establishment it's like
you're telling me that this
establishment literally exists to screw
the poor over and help the rich
and you're like calling joe biden your
friend you're saying that you like
elizabeth warren that she's a decent
person
how do you expect anyone to take you
seriously dude don't you get it
bernie was only complaining because it
was sour grapes elizabeth warren was
worth what 5 million bucks
the bidens are worth i think like 16
million pelosi with her husband worth
like 200.
and so there's bernie with his humble
174k
and he was you know living in his little
little vermont house and then
all of a sudden people started saying we
like this guy they bought his book he
became a millionaire
and all of a sudden his millionaire
buddies were like come on come on
and he was like okay okay i'm in the
club i'm in the club tim if you wrote a
best-selling book you could be a
millionaire too is that that's what he
said that's right yeah
yeah i don't think it's that i just
isn't it i think that it's because he
hates trump
and he's so s got tds so hard
which is sad but that's what i think it
is no because here's the thing uh this
is a cliche i understand that this is
sort of the conventional wisdom at this
point and everyone said this but if
there was a candidate who actually had a
could stand a chance to go up against
trump i do think would be bernie sanders
yeah i think working class people
actually like bernie sanders in a way
that they don't most of the other
candidates that the left was trying to
put up
five years ago you think five years ago
five years ago i don't think bernie
would have won
against trump but i think he would have
stood a better chance than like biden
five years ago bernie sanders said in an
interview with vox
he was asked about open borders and he
said that is a koch brothers proposal
yeah
well we are not for open borders now
he's on the stage being like we gotta
decriminalize
all border crossings free health care
and then dude the billionaires are bad
but not the ones funding joe biden he's
all right yeah
trump is a billionaire he's bad well
back then he was also saying
millionaires are bad because he wasn't
a millionaire now it's just billionaires
what happens when he becomes a
billionaire he's like trillionaires like
jeff bezos cannot run
this country it's ridiculous yep it's
funny because
uh so joe biden gets gets more donations
from higher income zip codes than donald
trump does that's true
and the other day he's raising tons of
money
from high like very very wealthy
billionaire investors
how are we in this is the craziest thing
to me i'm talking to some of these
leftists sometimes i'll tweet him and
stuff and i'm like i don't understand
how you guys found yourselves
on the side of the billionaires like
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg literal
billionaires
and you're like well i think they're all
right and i'm just like i'm asking so
many people do me a favor like you don't
like trump right
okay that's fine you don't have to like
trump can you say trump is bad
joe biden is bad i'll do it first trump
is bad
joe biden is bad your turn and they
won't do it they won't do it
how how is the revolution on the side of
the
like conglomerates the international
interests the corporations the
billionaires
the crony establishment politicians it's
almost like it actually has nothing to
do with helping the poor it's almost as
if the democratic party has no interest
in that at all and it's just about
getting their own radically left-wing
political agenda across that just
happens to be trendy with the
intellectual elite
including most tech millionaires and
billionaires this is the weird thing
like what are republicans doing
to be fair this is this was interesting
no no jake tapper
and wolf blitzer were just ragging on
nancy pelosi because the republicans
have conceded on the coveted relief bill
this is the this is the mind-blowing
thing
i have to now i used to say like you
know what i don't know what the
republicans are doing i think they're
trash the same
you know like there's rhinos and dinos
they see people who want to get an
office
just give me the power i'll do whatever
i want i'm not a fan of that i'm a big
fan of republican policy for the most
part even when they when they do
actually meet it but i like principal
yeah now i'm like talking to my family
i'm like they're like what are the
republicans doing for us
well well actually the republicans just
like caved to the democrats on all the
covet stuff to get the bill passed so
that 25 million americans can get their
unemployment benefits in this crisis and
nancy pelosi said no
and it was so bad wolf blitzer called
her out members of her own
party i saw that jake tapper just called
her out wow jake tapper said
it seems like the republicans have moved
your way
on this and you should you could take
yes for an answer
and she was like no no no they're
they're moving the goal post they say
we are doing it they're doing it and
you've got actual democrats i think it
was mark rose
he said the democrats need to learn how
to declare victory and sort of walk away
and you like walk away from this they've
won
nancy pelosi is like here's the things
we want and trump was like
okay you got it well i mean we don't
really want it
yeah so now she's been holding up the
whole time and it's really messed up
because i see
i see some some resistance democrats
like really desperate they hate trump so
much
and they're like it's actually trump's
fault this isn't getting passed
and then cnn is like actually it's the
democrats and i'm like dude when
cnn is on the side of the republicans it
must be really bad 100
really bad that's the weirdest thing to
me it's the republicans who are trying
to help the poor
yeah i never thought i'd see that day
well yeah i mean again and again i'm no
fan of the republican party i would tend
to argue that at least like the
principles behind conservative thought
tend to be better for poor people
because i think the government's just
done an invisible job attempting to help
them but i i totally get what you're
saying
it's really sad with the first covert
relief bill i'm not as familiar with the
second one so if you'd like to break
that same
same one okay because the first one was
literally well but the first uh the
first ballot was literally just a
handout to the richest people in the
country
for the the first coveted relief belt
yeah well i don't know
i'm talking about the first ballot that
i did several months ago it was the
largest transfer of wealth which has
occurred in all of human history and
most of it went to the wealthiest people
in the country and in the world frankly
basically they gave uh
the federal reserve i believe 450
billion dollars
so that they could leverage that to give
out about 4.25 trillion
in low interest loans they're the
largest companies in the country and
then
small businesses had to go through the
small business administration which got
a total of 350 billion and usually deals
with about 30 billion
over the course of a year and now had to
give out 350 billion
over the course of several weeks and so
what happened was there was an insane
amount of fraud a lot of these small
businesses didn't get the money 60
of the businesses that closed during
this lockdown are never going to reopen
but look what happened the richest
people in the country got these
interest-free loans from the government
and now they're going to be able to buy
up all of the assets of the small
businesses that went under during
covenant and it's just going to be a
massive consolidation
over power and that's what the democrats
and republicans gave to us
in response to a pandemic and there's
more and there's more
the lockdowns destroyed the small
businesses and the big box stores and
amazon
flourished and their stock prices
skyrocketed so if you were a mom and pop
shop that sold you know bikes
you're done but walmart they're good
they can sell all the bikes in the world
now we did see some stories where like
in michigan they would put like plastic
wrap up to block there's like you can't
buy this no one's allowed to buy these
products it's the weirdest thing yeah
but what's crazy to me is how i mean and
this is mostly a phenomenon of democrat
states with democratic governors the
republicans weren't really doing this
for the most part
but you look at these movie theaters
they decided to just
end the movie industry that's really
weird to me
yeah it's really really weird like even
right now movie theaters are shut down
in some states for
no reason none why it's almost like they
were like oh yeah movie theaters
i hate those just shut them down they're
gone it's a weird arbitrary recirculated
air and dirty chairs
i'm imagining like you know you got like
uh what's what's a good state
uh phil murphy in new jersey the
governor he's like
they're like sir which businesses should
we shut down and he remembers like when
he was a little kid like eating popcorn
in a movie theater watching you know
ninja turtles or something or what i
don't know
star wars and then like some guy some
like older kid bullied him and pushed
him down and they all laughed at him and
spilled his food
and then he's like no movie theater none
of the girls
none of the girls he asked to go to the
movies we're getting rid of the movie
theaters
there's no reason and that's what we got
the big box stores made billions in
stock value
the wealth of these people skyrocketed
small mom and pop shops are gone
yep and the craziest thing is it's the
republicans who are saying that was a
bad move
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time